[Musique]
je m'appelle simon pickard sénégal ait
été privé la mission au service de la
vérité repousser les limites du savoir
voilà la mission des scientifiques était
bien j'ai tout et ces deux aventuriers
qui partent à la recherche des yétis
pour pouvoir montrer au monde entier
qu'ils existent réellement
et puis je vous raconte pas la fin ce
serait dommage leur recommande pour un
public familial c'est très bien fait
peut-être que pour connaître quelqu'un
il faut d'avoir l'aimé
avec ce désir sa mélancolie
j'avoue que je suis encore ému pourquoi
parce que j'avais lu le livre en fête
donc je trouve que ça reprend tout à
fait les sentiments de la petite famille
en fête tout au long d'une vie
l'histoire d'une fratrie
je trouvais ça très émouvant ok c'est tu
devais employer un mot pour me
caractérise et qui choisit quoi oui on
table il faut tu t'es une famille a peur
congolaise quoi voilà donc le père
qu'énorme qui revient qu on voit tout le
temps d'un film qui est très sympathique
très beaux paysages bon esprit et bien
divertissant
[Musique]